back for the first time here in a couple
of years the damn short film festival
once again welcoming film Buffs to
Boulder City here to talk about the
festival Lee Lanier the director of
continuity but really one of the
founders of this incredible event and
for all the people at home who don't
know what the damn short film festival
is how would you wrap it up into a
sentence or two
we screened many short films from all
over the world over five days in Boulder
City so five days it starts in February
yes February 16th through 20th okay and
we're looking at some video of past
performances or past events I know that
was held inside the theater there this
year you know with covid it was virtual
for the last two years I believe now
this year it's back different location
though yes Elaine K Smith building in
downtown Boulder City so it's very close
to the old location great and for folks
at home who haven't been to Boulder City
it's such a great spot to go walk around
and enjoy there's great food so many
other things to do now as far as the
films go you said 153 films this year
153 films and 31 different programs and
what is the variety of films let's say
someone's into comedy you know there's
drama there's everything right
everything the programs are arranged
semantically but we have comedy drama
animation sci-fi horror documentary
Nevada filmmakers local filmmakers
students filmmakers also excellent so
everything you can think of we have
pretty much so not only for every age of
audience but also every age of filmmaker
you kind of have uh you know from from
college students all the way up to
professionals yeah students and
professionals and everything in between
excellent it's now as far as getting
tickets to go see the event
um you know maybe you want to watch a
couple maybe you want to watch the whole
thing how does it how does that work you
can buy tickets or passes for the entire
event online
damnstartfilm.org okay but you can pick
and choose what you'd like to see got it
okay so you have a little bit of variety
a little okay and you know when you go
there to watch these films somebody who
doesn't maybe know what a short film
mean What's the timing of these we're
not talking about two hour feature films
no one to 40 minutes okay so literally
one to 40 minutes although most of them
are like eight to twelve minutes or so
so I mean you say one minute I mean
essentially the length of a commercial
for some of them but it tells the story
it does and that's the point is to try
to find really interesting good stories
for our audience and Lee before uh
before we go to commercial break why is
this so important not only to Boulder
City but the film community in general
well it's a really important art forms
for films but this gives a chance for
filmmakers to have their films in front
of a live audience which is a fantastic
way to see these as opposed to say just
online oh yeah things
it's nice to see faces and see things in
person Lee thank you so much for joining
us here at this very early hour we
always appreciate your time go check it
out we're going to put more information
up on our website as well if you'd like
to get tickets well good day after the
break